well it's going to be zach pleesak
tonight we do know that he will be the
northeast ohio ford dealer starting
pitcher hernandez does a good job of
putting the ball in play
but he does not here that's only the
sixth strikeout in 59 plate appearances
for hernandez this year but police act
closed it by him one down
there's a ball scalded to left
but and a snow cone catch by mercado who
looks in that glove and says yeah had it
all the
way
102 billies garcia and that ball is
rifled down the left-field line and that
is a fair ball it looked like the the
ball dude down there
kind of gave it a
an effort it's gonna say a half
something or other effort
but what the heck dude that's a live
ball
93 down a little bit in
i love seeing a dollas aggressive early
in the count
there quickly
it's not for you dude
come on
a nice backhanded play by ramirez
thought about going to third long throw
is in time good stretch by you chang
and the inning is over the rangers
strand a pair the indians are coming
back txu energy numbers for
jake latz here has what he has done this
season i think he might have something
of course he was with houston earlier
this year
they do a pretty good job of that in
general the o2 pitch that one popped up
shallow right field peters making it
clear it's his ball one away
works pretty quickly the 2-1 pitch and
that's a breaking ball lifted high in
the air out to left field might be
playable though right near the wall it
is martin takes care of it
two up two down
one-two pitch
and that one is popped up again back at
first base nathaniel lowe is there and
it's a perfect one two three
first inning for jake latz and
the family happy with it they should be
and up comes oscar mercado
nears the wind and the 2-0 pitch
there's a ball deep left field high up
into the bleachers goodbye
third home run of the year for oscar
mercado
the indian strike first take a
one-nothing lead as jake latz receives
his major league baptism here in inning
number two
because the first pitch he did go with
the late kick there it is
bounced right side sliding stopped by
miller so the first night in time
everybody's safe and the bases are
loaded
normally good command of his pitches
he's fighting himself tonight just two
more strikes than balls thrown to this
point
everybody goes on the 3-2 and he got him
looking
oh did he lock him up he needed to make
a good pitch and boy did he ever
strikes out peters the rangers leave him
loaded
[Applause]
there's strike three called good
breaking ball that time to strike out
jose ramirez and jake latz with his
third strikeout tonight after that
conversation and after that big home run
and all the excitement and the promise
of going to the big leagues and she
passed away before he had the
opportunity to give her that
exciting news and he smashes this one
out to the gap right center field and
that one back to the warning track
hernandez can move and he does quickly
to second base
swing and a miss he went fishing police
sack with a much needed strikeout right
there his third of the night
keeps that runner stranded a third two
down
took the sting out
popped him up on the changeup
great job of pitching by zach policek
holds a one-nothing lead halfway through
here's
chang right field
deep back is peters on the track at the
wall he leaps he can't get it it's gone
a home run
hugh chang's
fifth home run of the year
his second home run of the series and
it's two nothing cleveland austin hedges
got a breaking ball a curveball and he
just blooped it into right field his
first time up there's a ball hit well
deep left field down the line it is
going to the home run porch
second home run of the inning
third solo shot of the night
and home run number six for austin
hedges it's three nothing cleveland
here's jason martin a single and the sac
bun
0-2
that ball hit hard deep out to right
that one carrying well it's gone
a two-run shot for jason martin
fifth home run of the year and he has
just made this one a ball game
it's three to two
right field near the line peters on the
run can't get there
chang's on his way to second mercado
scores and you will hold at second base
with a two out rbi double extending the
indians lead to four to two
and then chang loops one in and the
indians get a run home
and there's a base in the right field
chang coming around third they're gonna
wave him home peter's throw to the plate
he is safe
boy that was a good throw too right on
the money
but uh two outs here off and you know
you're going to score
he got the footage right before it uh
hit the tag on home plate grandma reyes
walked his last time up
there's a drive to deep left field
go on to the bleachers
home run number 23 for the four animal
and it's 6-2 cleveland
and miller shoots one up and got nice
diving stop they get one at second
indians get a run in miller beats it out
he could have had an rbi single instead
he'll settle for an rbi fielder's choice
and it's 7-2
took a while to find the one he wanted
and klosse's 0-2 offering
is a ground ball to miller and owen has
that for out number one
swinging and a miss hit hedges held on
he strikes him out two down
trying to put the finishing
touches on a 7-2 indians victory
[Applause]
and a liner caught that'll do it book it
the indians
even the series
[Applause]